it's an organization that's extremely
contemporary Islamic militancy is a
contemporary phenomenon indeed terrorism
over the centuries has always been very
modern it's a modern creation it's part
of our world it reflects our world it's
not something that comes from outside
either several centuries ago and is some
kind of throwback that emerges erupt in
the present day nor is it something that
is these days very distance as we found
over the last 15 years this is very much
embedded in our modern globalized world
the terrorists use what we use social
media they are often ahead of the curve
in fact I usually seems like proko
cameras don't have the program cameras
are absolutely astonishing I mean these
are no cameras a kind of used for
extreme sports very often and you stick
it here or here and it sends
point-of-view footage back to wherever
you want it to go basically you can keep
yourself well you can broadcast it these
days and we've seen these programmers
being used particularly by french
militants actually in the last couple of
years what we haven't quite got to yet
is the live stream from a point of view
camera during a terrorist attack we've
got everything up to there we've had
people taking pictures during an attack
and then uploading them that kind of
thing and that is absolutely our age it
says the terrorists are of our age just
using our technology in a very dark way
and that's what we need to recognize is
we're going to confront it we can't keep
saying they're mad do we have to contest
our ideas as well but I've often set the
meetings where I've said you know look
it isn't it dangerous if we start
succumbing to this idea that somehow is
or as some sort of deviant
I've been clearly there a very difficult
philosophy to to in any way interact
with but it's not a mental illness if
you're a believer in Islamic state you
feel they have a coherent manifesto
which can build your life around the
first thing the first step to
confronting the ideology is clearly to
understand it now if you're starting
from the point of view that that is
irrational you're not going to
understand it from from their point of
view it's amazing arrest not silly
rational so take the Islamic state there
one of the major attractions of the
Islamic state for people in the region
and obviously they are atrociously
brutal and they use coercive fear as
their primary mode of controlling
populations they also attract people by
playing on tribal differences by
offering economic incentives and by
offering security in a civil war that
other parties cannot offer now that is a
rational strategy that's not some crazed
psychopath in a cave somewhere that's
people who understand the state and and
understand how to use power and terror
and one of the interesting things about
the Islamic state which people often
forget is that many of the senior
commanders within it are ex bath party
former Saddam Hussein loyalists so they
grew up in a very state orientated
environment the Bespin localized isn't
it that's Iraq Syria why is it why you
know couple months ago I was in Tunisia
there was a guy who kills 13 main
British tourists subscribed he said to
his not mistake company as before that
that was in Nairobi it was the Westgate
shopping mall it was some al-shabaab
affiliate but again saying we quite like
the idea of subscribing to Islamic state
why is that
that rebadging happening is it just
because it is the terrorism gluten is
your partly I mean we have to be careful
about as we did with al-qaeda
immediately after the 9/11 attacks
labeling everything today is Amex Tate
and there is the Islamic state there are
also some affiliates their relations
with the Islamic state are actually
quite varied some are very close some
are really pretty tenuously connected
there's also still al-qaeda and there's
still a whole range of other groups but
partially connected to al-qaeda or just
independent by the Taliban and
Afghanistan that good old Taliban we all
remember still reversing that irrational
by comparison yeah who now look kind of
more moderate in a very weird sense we
just talked about I think we're both
we're both of you it's important to you
can't but labor this too much this is a
repugnant organisation in every possible
respect
how will it be defeated when it
eventually does collapse under the way
you've said your own contradictions or
will it be militarily if we go in the
backfield
there's one fundamental floor with all
Islamic militancy quite apart from as
you say there's moral repugnance they
were boring since then the act which all
right
people and repelled by unless I have a
very good reason not to be and that is
it doesn't actually work it's not a very
good way of running car they won't they
won't they won't make the trains run on
time they can't guarantee security very
long and as you've seen again and again
that the general rhetoric works the
jihad jihad global war when you drill
down into what it means on the ground
it's extremely unpleasant and
communities again and again over the
last 15 years whether it's al Qaeda
whether it's Islamic state reject that
eventually partly for pragmatic reasons
partly for moral reasons and partly for
cultural reasons but it eventually falls
apart and if you're over at the Ministry
of Defense in Whitehall planning
strategy for the next ten years your
advice I'm guessing for the book is is
pretty simple one element of it is
simply this
don't try and decapitate the leadership
because it doesn't work well
decapitating the leadership is pretty
unpredictable I mean it's not a bad
thing to do I know taking out major
militants who pose a threat is pretty
sensible it just can have very
unpredictable you don't know what's
going to question you know what's coming
next and you know part of the reason for
the strength of Islamic state is because
we've seen a decline of al Qaeda part of
that is due to bin Laden being killed so
it's do it but be prepared for the
consequences okay Jason Birk good to
talk to you thank you